the jurogan experience one of the things
about chappelle that's fascinating is he
doesn't use any social media
he doesn't use anything you know he uh
he consumes
right like he'll go on youtube and watch
videos he'll
he's interested in things but he doesn't
[ __ ] around with anything that has
anything to do with him
and he doesn't he doesn't post things he
does he's not showing you his life
but he's got accounts yeah he's got
logins he's only got one
and he recently started it it was for uh
instagram to let people know that um hbo
max
was uh using the chappelle show and he
wasn't getting paid for it
yeah so and that worked so they pulled
it off of netflix and they pulled it off
at hbo max now
and now that's wild wild i mean [ __ ]
do that i mean
that to me was like i mean i i get
tweets
because i work on comedy central i get
tweets like i don't support you because
you guys haven't paid chappelle as if i
have any [ __ ] thing to do
right it's like twitter people are
attacking me it's like when people
attacked me
because i was playing a club that louis
had played that you know week or
something it's like well that's
do you think i own levity live in west
nyack new york you know
but um but i was just thinking what
talent like chappelle can just say pull
this off and they
and they pull it off i love that he just
moved to
ohio out of the whole deal he's been in
ohio for a long time as a michigander
i'm like wait you can have a career in
showbiz and this is what's
fascinating about what's happening right
now you guys can have a career in
showbiz and not be in new york in l.a
yeah well he did it on purpose because
he wants to be in a place where people
are normal
he lives in a small town he knows
everybody at his grocery store he knows
everybody at the coffee shop
and he's like a normal resident of the
community i love it and he's taking a
number
asking for sliced turkey breast and
someone is like that's one of the
greatest stand-up comments
ever lived he lives right down the
street he lives on a farm
he's a fascinating character yeah i love
him yeah i love him i love hanging out
with him he's just
so fascinating comics always say that to
know him and interact with him
and uh that's that's awesome yeah no
he's
great he's always been great too i mean
i met him when he was 19.
so did he not then get really well paid
from the chappelle show he must have no
he didn't no
he didn't well he walked away from a big
park a big chunk
right and that the thing that he walked
away for
i was dealing with the same people at
comedy central at the time because
that's when stan hope and i were doing
the show the man show and it was rough
like
they there was a bunch of people that
were not comedians and
they were not creative but they wanted
to put all this creative input
into the show particularly because they
had the chance to put their greasy
little fingers all over it because
adam and jimmy had left and then they're
like okay now we're gonna mold this into
what they
what we want catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience